hey guys my name is Jess it is the 22nd
of September and here's the gaming show
where we talk about the knees first up
resident evil 7 SPC system requirements
have been revealed the game stream page
is listed the minimum and recommended
specs so you can check out what kinda
graphics quality you'll be scared out
here pass it to run the game at 1080p
and 30 frames per second you'll need an
intel i5 4460 or FX 6300 and a gtx 760
or r7 260x the recommended specs come in
a tad higher calling for an i7 3770 or
AMD equivalent and a gtx 960 or r9 280x
to run the game at 1080p and 60 frames
per second an updated version of
Resident Evil sevens demo was also
recently released on the PlayStation
Store if you feel like putting yourself
through that next up yahoo has revealed
that a 2014 breach has resulted in 500
million accounts being compromised yahoo
said they believe a state-sponsored
actor was responsible for the hack data
obtained may have included names email
addresses phone numbers birth dates and
passwords yahoo said it has no reason to
believe the hackers still have access to
their network but if you haven't changed
your password since 2014 that's probably
a thing you'll want to do now Yahoo are
also implementing extra security
measures like invalidating unencrypted
security questions and they recommend
you change non Yahoo passwords too if
you attempt to use the same one end of
PSA finally he won't be able to play the
quarter final ranking iceland team in
FIFA 17 and his why according to Iceland
Soccer Association president guy at
Torstensson EA offered them $15,000 for
the rights to put their side in the game
Iceland believed this figure to be too
low and made a counteroffer which EA did
not accept Torstensson explains they are
the ones buying these rights and they
almost want it for free the performance
of the year is show that we're quite a
good team and many would like to play
with our team its add to the players but
the criticism should be towards EA
sports Iceland's men's national team is
not appear
in a FIFA game before fever 17 is due
out on sep tember 27 and xbox one owners
with an EI access membership can start
playing the full game right now let me
know what you thought about today's
stories in that comment section in the
head to gain slip for news one titanfall
2 and hit man and I'll be back with the
top five stories of the whole week
tomorrow